mais tout de suite quelques images de la
télévision roumaine c'est ce qui se
passe quotidiennement dans les villes
roumaines les fidèles de ceausescu sont
traqués je voulais dire et ils tentent
de fuir ou de s'échapper alors voici
l'une de ses scènes filmées sur le vix
je vais vous expliquer sur le vif par la
télévision roumaine
voici l'une de ses scènes l'homme que
vous allez voir est un poète célèbre en
roumanie mais il était très proche du
régime ceausescu il était donc très
riche mais très impliqué il tente
maintenant de convaincre les autres
qu'il soutient les insurgés
regardez attendez la fin des combats
n'oubliez pas les consignes de l'armée
ne lui compliquer pas la tâche dans la
tourmente de l'insurrection
un poète officielle prise au piège et
qui tente de gagner du temps il était
17h30 heure locale cet après midi
lorsque quelqu'un dans une rue de
bucarest insurgés a soudain reconnu
l'illustrent adrian tu pas ou n'est ce
coup écrivain choyée par le régime
couvert de gloire et de richesse par le
dictateur déchu
il promet aujourd'hui de s'expliquer il
tente de rattraper le vent de l'histoire
sans grand succès
n'écoutez pas pas ou n'est ce coup c'est
lui qui vous a crétiniser abba pas ou
n'est ce coup n'écoutez pas ce criminel
tout à coup les tirs reprennent le cri
d'une femme dans la foule mettez vous à
l'abri je vous en prie et puis la
panique un instant adrian paunescu a
tenté d'en profiter pour échapper à la
colère
son but le consulat des états unis où il
veut se réfugier à quelques dizaines de
mètres de là quelques dizaines de mètres
et la vis aux peut-être mais autour de
lui la foule s'est refermé comme un étau
l'ancien chouchou du dictateur n'est
plus qu'un gros sommes dérisoires qui ne
sait pas s'il va sauver sa peau santé
lui dessus
ah bah pas une escroquerie les uns
tandis que d'autres le protège dents
rempart de corps pour éviter le pire
quelques coups de feu en l'air
ce sont les soldats qui gardent le
consulat et qui le prennent enfin sous
leur protection
le poète qui ne disait pas la vérité ne
sera pas exécutée c'était en fin d'après
midi à bucarest des images tournées par
l'une de nos équipes à bucarest la donne
en effet une idée des scènes terribles
qui se multiplient